how to report an independent t-test
according to APA style first of all what
is an independent t-test an independent
t-test tests whether there is a
difference between two independent
samples more specifically we want to
compare the means of the two independent
samples we want to know if there is a
significant difference between these
means but how to report an independent
t-test reporting an independent t-test
according to APA style requires
presenting key statistics in a clear
concise manner here's a general
guideline on how to report the results
in six steps finally I will show you how
to automatically create the
interpretation of your data number one
descriptive statistics Begin by
presenting the means and standard
deviations for each group example the
means call for group a was m equal to
5.110 as D equal to
1.25 and for group b m equal to 6.75 and
SD equal to
1.44 number two test statistic report
the T value degrees of freedom and
p-value example the t-test revealed a
significant difference between the two
groups t58 equal to
4.25 P smaller than
0.001
t58 represents the T value followed by
degrees of freedom in parenthesis P
smaller than
0.001 is the p-value adjust this
recording to your results for example P
equal to
0.045 P equal to
0.25 and so on and so forth number three
effect size it's also common and
recommended to report an effect size
such as Cohen's D this gives the reader
a sense of the magnitude of the
difference between groups Beyond
statistical significance example the
effect size for the difference was large
D equal to
0.80 for the interpretation of the
effect size you can use this table
number four confidence interval if
applicable or if it provides added value
to your report you can include a 95
confidence interval for the difference
between means example the 94 confidence
interval for the difference in means
range from
1.20 to 2.30 number five interpretation
follow the statistics with a plain
language into irritation of what the
results mean in the context of your
study example thus there is a
significant difference between the means
of the two samples whether the
difference is significant or not depends
on whether the calculated p-value is
smaller or larger than the specified
significance level the significance
level is usually five percent if the
p-value is smaller than 0.05 there is a
significant difference otherwise not
number six graphs and tables while not
always necessary visual aids like bar
graphs or box plots can be helpful and
Visually representing the data if you
use them ensure that they are clearly
labeled and referenced in the text
tables should be formatted according to
apa guidelines and here is a complete
example participants in group a m equal
to 5.1 1 0 SD equal to 1.25 scored lower
than those in group b m equal to 6.75 SD
equal to 1.40 the t-test revealed a
significant difference between the two
groups t equal to 4.25 P smaller than
0.001 the effect size for this
difference was large with Cohen's D
equal to
0.80 the 95 confidence interval for the
difference in means range from 1.20 to
2.30 of course when you calculate an
independent t-test online with data tab
the summary in words is automatically
generated for you just copy your data
into this table select your variables
and click on summary inverts
remember when writing up your results
aim for clarity and precision ensure
that someone reading a report can easily
understand the statistical analysis
you've conducted and implications of the
findings thanks for watching and I hope
you enjoyed the video
foreign